Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program today, Democratic Congressman Ro Khanna,
who represents California's 17th District. It's
great to have you back on. And it's you know,
the last time you were on was before the
Russian invasion of Ukraine. So I think
maybe we would start there. Weeks ago, there
were reports, seemingly credible reports,
that Russia sort of had the resources for about
another ten days of what they started with.
It's obviously been more than ten days. And what's
taking place on the ground has shifted to some
degree. What's your outlook now based on what
you've been briefed on that you can talk about,
about what the longevity of
this might potentially be?
Speaker 4: I don't underestimate the Russians. In
fact, Charles Lester had sent me an article, is a
expert on what Russia did in Syria, just reminding
us how brutal Russia can be. And they spent almost
a decade in Syria where they did in Aleppo,
what they're doing now, two cities in Ukraine
and they've had the same record in Georgia. So I
admire and support unconditionally the Ukrainian
resistance, but I don't think we should be a
rose eyed in terms of how difficult the this
is going to be and how ruthless Russia is.
Speaker 1: There are some, including to some
degree Noam Chomsky and others who have focused
on the what they see as the futility of resistance
against the overwhelming power of Russia, and
that Ukraine should essentially give Russia
some stuff and try to end hostilities as quickly
as possible. Not a perspective that many others.
There are many others who very much
disagree with that perspective.
What's your sense of what Ukraine should be doing?
Speaker 4: Well, my job as an American lawmaker is
to support Ukraine and to provide make sure
we're providing them with military weapons,
which we are, and make sure that they're
getting the resources that they need. Make
sure that the president's wolanski has the
unconditional support of the united states.
I think the president has done a tremendous
job with secretary blinken in rallying naito.
I have called out countries like india because
i'm the vice chair of the india caucusing. We've
got to be unified in condemning Putin. But I also
have said that we have to, at the end of the day,
have a negotiated settlement and the United States
should be working towards that to do whatever we
can before that. But strengthening Ukraine and
having this resistance succeed, I think, is one
step to that, because it weakens Putin's hand. If
Putin has to be in a weak position to even accept
some compromise, I mean, Zelensky has floated
compromises. He has said he's open to seeing, but
even not even being neutral in certain cases.
But Putin is the one, as my understanding is,
and coming to the table, both.
Speaker 1: In terms of U.S. troops
on the ground. Joe Biden from the beginning said
that that's not something that he's willing to do
and there's significant support for that, but
not total support for that red line. What's
your position on on boots on the ground?
Speaker 4: No. And the president has been
correct. He has been wise. He has been
restrained. He has done everything he
can to support the Ukrainian people
but not get us into a war with Russia.
I don't think anyone in America will want
that, especially when you have got Putin making
terribly concerning statements about using nuclear
weapons against Great Britain. I mean, the last
thing we want to do is to get into a world war.
Speaker 1: Two different things that are touchy,
to say the least. And if there's anything you
can tell us about them, it would be great.
One is increased speculation, including after a
recent video that Vladimir Putin is ill looking,
swollen, gripping a table, just a very unhealthy
appearance and lots of speculation about that as
a possible factor in his actions. On the
other hand, speculation that there has,
without a doubt, intelligence experts are paid
to provide all options to elected officials
and that it would be unusual that the question of
could Putin be assassinated, would not have come
up. Not that anyone's planning to do it, but that
this is what intelligence people are paid to do,
provide every option. Can you weigh in
at all on either of those two things?
Speaker 4: I certainly am not privy to any
knowledge that is an out there in the American
public. So I guess first I would just say that it
would be absolutely wrong. It is not. The United
States policy should not be the United States
policy to try to assassinate a sitting head of
state of another country. And I would vigorously
oppose something like that. And it's nothing that
I have heard of being planned. And I don't think
in any way is the policy of this administration.
The second point about Putin's health, I
mean, I've read about the same speculation,
but I don't think that can inform a policy. We
have to be governed by the basic facts of what
we can confirm, and that is that we need
to continue to help the Ukrainian people
have as tough a resistance as possible with the
hopes that when Putin is sufficiently pushed back
that we can have a negotiated settlement.
Speaker 1: Last question on this. Do you.
Aside from what would be acceptable responses
to it, where it's a different question? Do
you agree with the perspective that a NATO's
expansion could legitimately be seen as a form
of aggression by Putin?
Speaker 4:
I don't think that that is the cause of this
war. I think that the cause of this war is
what Putin himself has written, that he wanted to
see Ukraine be part of Russia and that he views
Ukraine historically as a part of Russia. And
that is that his own words, his own rationale. So
we can put aside whether the question on NAITO
expansion and how much to expand NAITO and what
that implication has for U.S. security and
US-Russia relations. But I don't think it
is anyway the proximate cause of this war.
Speaker 1: Okay. So kind of on that note
and into this next topic, there are some on
Twitter and in sort of lefty media circles
that have sort of turned on you in the last
six months. And the idea being Roxana isn't
progressive enough. He's too friendly with big
tech. He's not willing to say something like,
for example. No, listen, I mean, Naito
expansion, if we had something equivalent going
on on our southern border with a
coalition involving other countries,
we would absolutely see it as aggression,
even if it's not the proximate cause.
Do you believe that the criticisms of you are
fair? Do you feel like you've changed in some way
over the last 6 to 12 months that there is more
sort of like Antero kind of sentiment happening
in some of the usual places on the Internet.
Speaker 4: I don't know. Do you think there
is that? I have a sense that I don't. We had
a big I had a big disagreement with I think
that. BLUMENTHAL Because I basically support the
president's policy on Ukraine. And there have been
people who have been critical of that. I haven't
had sort of moral equivalence between America and
Russia, but I don't see that. I think Putin is a
dictator who is violating territorial sovereignty
and is clearly in the wrong here and that he has
to be resisted. And I know there are some people
who are more sympathetic to Putin's perspective
on it. And Max Blumenthal perspective. I just
philosophically disagree with that. Strongly
disagree with that. And I'm much more on Joe
Biden's side than Max Blumenthal side.
And I guess maybe that has led to some
progressives being upset. And I guess the
only other thing I noticed that some folks
are upset is that I'm speaking with Senator
Manchin about trying to get a climate deal.
Look, I have been for the boldest vision on
climate. I chaired the big oil hearings and
exposed a lot of their disinformation for
the last 40 years. But I care so much about
the climate that I want to get something done
before the midterms. And, you know, if talking to
Senator Manchin is unacceptable, then basically
people are saying, let's throw up our hands and
get a climate deal. That's not acceptable to me.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it seems to be this debate that's
not new about pragmatism versus idealism, which
is it seems in doing some research before talking
to you today that some of the disappointment,
for lack of a better term, is that some feel
that what was previously a much stronger alignment
with someone like Bernie Sanders has shifted into
being much more accepting of the status quo. And
maybe the mansion stuff is being perceived by some
as being too accepting of the status quo,
whereas it sounds like you see it as being a
realist and a pragmatist because that's who you
have to negotiate with and work with right now.
Speaker 4: Yeah. And I look, I've always been
a pragmatic progressive. I've always been a
progressive capitalist. I used to get criticized
when I was a Bernie campaign as a co-chair,
people saying, Oh, well, why are you making
this argument about how Bernie is an FDR
and actually a progressive capitalist, and why
are you not being more confrontational? But
I guess I haven't changed. I think people's
perceptions, they're getting to know who I
really am. And that is someone who believes in
Medicare for All and has fought for it through
public college and has fought very canceling
student loans. I was just out in a rally and
actually publishing an op ed in the post tomorrow
on it, someone who's fought on Yemen against wars
overseas, but also someone who believes in
innovation, believes in entrepreneurship,
believes that ultimately you do have value in a
free enterprise system. If it can be fair with
health care and education for everyone and someone
who's pragmatic, who wants to take the progressive
movement and say, okay, we've got to now get
to the 50% mark so that we can get policy done.
That's just one messaging. So I think describing
me as a a pragmatic progressive, as someone who is
100% committed to the policies, but a more of a
coalition building a little bit more aspirational
would be accurate. And that may not be of appeal
to everyone. No politician get it, but it is who
I am. And I would say it's been consistent in
how I have been since I've been in Congress.
Speaker 1: So let's talk about 2022. You and
your 434 colleagues are up for reelection. As
is always the case every two years. We also
have some important governors races. A third
of the Senate is up for reelection. Elizabeth
Warren recently wrote a piece where she says
it's really not looking good for Democrats. I tend
to agree. I am particularly worried because I look
at some of these races, for example, Monday in the
Pennsylvania Senate race to pick one. Yeah, there
was the Democratic debate where you have John
Fetterman and Conor LAMB and Malcolm Kenyatta and
a woman whose last name I believe is Khalil. But
I don't remember right now on the Democratic side,
on the Republican side, you had this television,
Dr. Mehmet Oz, as well as Dave McCormick and
others. In looking at it, I love Fetterman
on policy. His debate was, I would call it
disastrous in terms of presentation. And when I.
Speaker 4: Look at that, I didn't I didn't follow
it. I mean, I yeah, the Bernie folks like him.
Speaker 1: I like him on policy. But when I
looked at the five Republicans, some of whom
are bonkers, I mean, they're out of this world
nuts. It looks like any of the five would do
better in debates against the four Democrats
that are running. And my concern do badly.
Speaker 4: What do I need to learn for the future?
Speaker 1: He seemed disoriented, to be
perfectly frank. He seemed unprepared
and confused at different times. It was weird.
I mean, I would recommend that you watch it. But
the greater point, given that you didn't
didn't watch that in particular, is
I'm very worried that as terrible and dangerous
as some of the Republican candidates are,
that the Democratic Party is is just not prepared
for what may be coming in November and that it's
going to be absolutely brutal. I mean, what's
your outlook on the way it's looking right now?
Speaker 4: It's a tough election. And I think
there are two things we need to do. One,
what Elizabeth Warren said, forget the student
loan. Pass something on climate to excite her
own a base. But I think it's beyond that. David
and I again, I don't know people everyone will
agree with me. But here's what I think. You know,
I was born in Philadelphia in 1976. I but I still
believe this is the greatest country in the
world. There are millions of people who want
to come to America, not go to China. I think
Democrats have to start with that. And then we
need to say there's a problem. Has this country
was deindustrialization. The jobs were shipped
to China. They were shipped to Mexico. And 50% of
this country. Is it participating in the wealth
generation and producing things? Well, districts
like mine have wealth piling up and benefiting
from globalization. So we understand why people
are angry. We understand why they keep voting
folks out. But we have a concrete plan to
bring good jobs, to have industrialization,
to bring economic prosperity to these communities.
And we're going to start to do it concretely, just
like Bobby Kennedy did in Bedford-Stuyvesant in
1964, bringing business, community labor together
and actually showing results. And I think
we've got to if we lead with that economic
message of economic revitalization. Look at
the numbers today. With the GDP going down
in the quarter, it's all because we're importing
things. It's all because of the trade deficit.
Why can't the Democratic Party become the party
of re industrialization, economic revitalization?
That to me is a not just a winning. This is
a true message. And it gives us the best shot
in, I think, winning back some of these places.
Speaker 1: Well, two thoughts on that one. It's
notably missing from the discussion about re
industrializing and bringing supply chains back
home. And both Republicans and Democrats talk
about it. We're going to do Made in the U.S.A.
Trump says that at every rally, Joe Biden's been
saying it. It's missing from that, that that will
make stuff products significantly more expensive.
And as an economy over 30 years, cumulatively,
the U.S. has opted for cheaper stuff that's
produced outside the country. We kind of have
to deal with the reality that everything would
be much more expensive if we brought our supply
chains back home, wouldn't we?
Speaker 4: Not necessarily. But look,
I mean. Well, there are two points. I mean,
yes, it may be more expensive instead of having
everything be made by slave labor conditions in
China and cheap imports. But the other possibility
is that we just massively increase productivity
in this country. We massively increase our
capacity to industrialize and grow. And that's
what we haven't done yet. Trump talks about it,
but he's not actually articulating a industrial
policy of actually having the government be
providing purchase agreements and loans in a
massive scale with private industry that bring
production back. And I think Biden, we're doing it
with the COMPETES Act and putting $20 billion in
Ohio, but we could be doing a lot more. So are you
saying if there are two alternatives, which is,
okay, get all of the cheap imports from China with
slave labor, that's always going to be cheaper
than building productive capacity in
the United States. But building lower
productivity and productive capacity in
the United States can also be inflationary.
It'll be less inflationary than just
offshoring to China. But I would argue
that most Americans would take the route
of increasing our productivity instead of
importing from China, both for national security
reasons and because of moral reasons of having
dignity if basic how workers are treated.
Speaker 1: So last thing on this and for today,
on on the economic message, I recently watched a
great Netflix docu series about Bobby Kennedy, and
the economic message worked extraordinarily well
in his campaign. Cut to short right in in his era,
he wasn't up against a Republican Party that had
very successfully weaponized imaginary cultural
issues, critical race theory textbooks, Dr. Seuss,
you know, Disney, all these different things, the
woke mind virus and all of these things. It's not
feeling like the economic message is smothering
these culture battles that the right has created
and is fighting. So what should be done? I just
don't see the message getting through.
Speaker 4: But as an economic message
linked with American patriotism, linked with the
hope and belief in the American story. When I've
gone to places like Paintsville, Kentucky,
Beckley, West Virginia, Galesburg, Illinois,
in places like the West Side of Chicago, where
manufacturing has left, but manufacturing is left.
And I talk about my story, my hope of America, in
my view that communities need to have the economic
opportunity for like kids in my district. Now it
tends to break through. Now I call greatness. I'm
relatively unknown. And so I haven't had millions
of dollars spent against me making me a boogeyman.
And maybe if I did, it would be harder than
being relatively unknown. But even people
who have more baggage, I think if you show up to
these communities, if you actually are delivering
something in these communities, and if you start
with I believe in America, I believe we're a good,
decent people. I believe we are going to remain
the greatest country in the world. Just every
Democrat may want to start if they believe with
that paragraph. And I think it puts people at
ease right now. I think so many people are
wondering whether we are judging that. You know,
there was a focus group in Pennsylvania. They said
Republicans are crazy. Democrats are preaching.
We have to get a sense where we can connect with
people and say, look, we have a real vision and
all those other things are distractions. That's
not going to help your kids get a better life.
It's not going to help us beat China. We have
a real plan and we've got to hammer that,
talk about that again and again and again and not
get sidetracked as they're trying to have us make.
I think it can work. I do. Am I 100% confident?
No. I mean, that's why I have elections.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah. No. And the difficulty
is when those other issues are meant to make
people afraid, that's the basis of
reactionary politics. It can be hard
for the sober but positive economic message
to shine through. But I think that's exactly
the challenge that that that you're talking
about. Congressman Ro Khanna from California,
17th District. Always great speaking with you.
Speaker 4: Thank you. Always enjoy it